c'est ce qu'on appelle un beau coup de
filet 30 véhicules de belell cylindr
saisis et 35000 € en espèce les
gendarmes d'azel ridau ont réussi à
mettre la main sur un réseau de trafic
de voitures plutôt bien organisé
l'escroquerie consistait pour les
escross à acheter des véhicules en
Belgique donc c'était des véhicules
fortement kilométrés les compteurs
étaient rabaissés fortement rabaissés et
à l'issue on y revendait les véhicules
via le boncoin sur sur la France entière
c'est donc sur ce site internet de vente
re particulier que les malfaiteurs
revendaient leur véhicules pour la
plupart d'origine étrangère ces arnaques
ont été découvertes en février 2013
grâce à une cliente suspicieuse les
gendarmes ont ensuite enquêté 7 mois
pour remonter le réseau grâce aux
adresses IP des malfaiteurs les escros
tous de Tours sont d'origine arménienne
turqu et russes et vendaient leurs
véhicules transformés partout en France
leur technique était bien ré ils se sont
branchés sur la prise diagnostic pour
décendre le compteur ils ont fait des
petites modifications éventuellement
entretien des pédales entretien de
certains bouton pour que véhicule
apparaisse à 129 ou 130000 on a
l'impression que la voiture elle est
nickel c'est complètement truqué en fait
voilà c'est complètement truqué on on a
une voiture qui est propre qui est bien
entretenue mais qui a en fait 250000 sur
les 15 personnes interpellées trois ont
été placées en détention provisoire et
trois sont aujourd'hui sous contrôle
judiciaire le montant total du préjudice
est estimé à 1200000 € et concernerait
220 véhicules